[VIDEO GAME MUSIC]
Hey there, Polycasters.
Rob here with a very special
announcement because today,
we are moving.
Well, not today, because
you're watching us
on the Google
Developers channel,
but the next episode
of "Polycast"
is going to be premiering
on our brand-new,
revamped Chrome
Developers channel.
That means you can
subscribe to that channel
and get notifications for
the kinds of shows you like,
shows about the web.
Along with "Polycast,"
we're going
to be moving our
British counterparts,
"HTTP 203" and
"Totally Tooling Tips."
As we create new shows, we'll be
premiering them on that channel
as well.
So click this annotation
to check it out,
tell your friends,
spread the word,
and I'll see you on
Chrome Developers.
[VIDEO GAME MUSIC]